you
hi everyone is Gerry I'm on leeches org
and I just got paired up playing a 15-2
game let's try d4 which my opponent have
fun no luck though
no no luck wishing all right let's go at
c4 alright Queens gambit declined and
hold off on declaring my night my king
Knight possibilities for both e 2 and F
3 probably just the Bishop g5 and then
III favoring Queen side development here
clearly
let's go III not a better spot for that
pawn and do I just go in for Knight f3
probably yeah so long term I could be
looking for a minority attack but I
guess now with this move black is
heading for a trump not not a trump
offski what am I trying to say something
would tee I believe yeah b6 forgetting
the exact name here o tartakower that's
it okay well I could probably go in for
just a capture on d5 right now now that
they've spent some time opening up a new
door for the bishop notice how I
captured one move sooner the bishop
could just come out along this diagonal
so maybe now is a moment where I could
release the tension in other words just
capture on d5 and can't be so bad with
follow-up idea Bishop d3 I have to be
careful because if I take on d5 I'm not
sure which way white our black will
recapture but if it's with the pawn then
I have some concern of some type of
Queen side majority I guess let's just
start out with capture let's consider
once more my other alternative is just
to play Bishop d3 or rook to c1 I'm
going to capture and I want a little bit
more clarity okay
so took with the knight now I have no
fear of let's say some Queen side pawn
roller c5 c4 at the moment there's
tension between the bishops I could
probably just go straight in for a
capture right here I'm helping the Queen
to develop
also if I capture the night this idea
can still present it can still show up
this c5c for stuff Bishop takes Queen
takes Knight takes pawn takes c5 will be
hitting soon and I could saddle black
with the hanging pawn structure hmm what
other candidate moves are there here I
don't have too many options so let's
just get this next move in do I capture
the knight on d5 first and then the
bishop let's so sure the move order
matters here and take the bishop let's
see what black does is there any
in-betweener okay just the recapture
pretty quiet position for sure play the
opening a little faster than usual in
another decision point here I could take
the knight or I could play rook to c1 I
don't know that I want to allow the
knight takes and then B takes I mean I
could I could do that I think the
computer would read you know these two
moves are around the same
my concern is that if I don't take the
night right now this bishop will turn
out to be a very strong piece so this is
something that has my attention if I
don't want this Bishop to be a factor
pointing at my king side I should take
right now and make sure there's a fixed
on on d5 blocking the bishop because I
could be sure Bishop d7 is hitting next
for black if I play rook C one or even
Bishop to d3
not sure what else to
Brooksie one Knight takes Knight Bishop
d3 hmm I'm going to play it very simple
just take and my only concern is some
type of pawn roller but I'll address
that when it comes I could also probably
take that into account because if I'm
playing Bishop d3 there is always this
concern of c-4 hitting with tempo if c5
happens you know the resulting structure
is a hanging pawn structure so black
would probably like to have more pieces
on board
with a hanging pawn structure so I'm
welcome to missus to some exchanges if
black is doing nothing at all I could
just be castling and put both rooks on
the C and D files to put pressure on
these pawns I have to be concerned about
any kind of push c4 or even d4 I'm
pretty sure this has to happen you're
striking at my center
I've played a position before where the
Queen goes and gives check and I'm fine
with just blocking and exchanging Queens
and taking with the King okay
I wonder hmm I'm considering Knight to
e5 just to welcome some more exchanges
and also be in a position to offset this
bishop in a way exert pressure on d5 hmm
he could be kicked with f6 but maybe
that's not such a bad move - I don't
think I would be upset if my knight gets
kicked back d3 is a fine a fine square
hmm I'm going to try for that also with
this move I'm basically saying that when
c5 happens I'm not going to be taking
and saddling black with the hanging pawn
structure but okay we're not there are
we so my ID it wasn't to support my
knight but rather to trade it very
simple position I believe I am slightly
better only because of my bishop I
believe I have the better Bishop here so
I can't do without castles look let's
get this in I'm one move away from
completing development it's probably
reading as
Zero's okay
well I don't believe I'm going to have
any issue with my opponent putting
pressure on my pawns I don't see any
kind of target hmm in a way I could see
after takes takes the a5 on running down
one of one of these two pawns could turn
out to be a target I think I should
capture this or something better I could
play for a little trick here right to c1
and if they defend c5 I have this
although they could play f5 I don't
think I want to allow c4 here let's
saddle black with the hanging pawn
structure and how about now rook a and
just rook to c1 striking at the c5 pawn
yeah let's do this
and I might I might actually do this
yeah rook c8 f5 okay so the Queen
stepping up this gives up this square so
Queen a4 is pretty appealing must be
said she just rakes the whole
fourth-ranked possibilities for Queen a5
exerting pressure on both bonds so I'm
just trying to figure out how to exactly
organize my pieces I may want to get on
this diagonal before it's too late
that's the other thing I don't think
that they could prevent me from playing
Queen a4 but they could prevent me from
playing Bishop f3 by playing d4 you know
Queen a for d4 concerns me maybe the
Queen here and some type of coordinated
attack against g2 so
play Bishop f3 and I anticipate you know
at some point the the bishops will be
exchanged they're playing very fast I
think that if they're not careful they
could really be under a lot of pressure
soon like on Queen Queen a4 queen a4 is
getting pretty serious let's also bear
in mind that their bishops unprotected
also I need a flight square let's get
Queen a4 in there see what they do I'm
expecting a five I think that's the
right approach primary reason behind it
is to stop Queen a5 so let's see what
black does Queen a5 that's another good
one I think
hmm
interesting time for a flight square I
think so
the b-pawn is poisoned because of rook
to be one and get the bishop also I have
to be on the lookout for queen bee four
or a five coupled with queen bee 4 and
if I'm ever taking a takes be then
there's a target okay they're going with
the flight square as well however that's
not the most reliable of flight squares
probably get this guy working huh I
think I want to be prepared to avoid the
Queen exchange on Queen before let's
start with this he's not doing anything
I might look for this kind of stuff
maybe even poke around at the Kings side
if I'm controlling this diagonal they'll
probably eventually have to play g6 get
a new flight square in there you know
they continue to play very fast hmm
Queen on f4 is pretty active piece
should I like to just double up though
against this guy I think I'm going to
try for that let's go here also rules
out any Queen takes b2 stuff I'm not
afraid of Queen before in this position
if the pawn has to take like this then
you know he's he's a bit more of a fixed
pawn in a way the likelihood that he
could push is not so great
he's black enough
d for right now this is maybe their
first think of the game good to see
hmm.well on d4 I'm planning to first
take the bishop and then okay and still
played pretty fast I mean might I just
be winning upon here Bishop takes Bishop
let's let's consider it so a moment to
calculate for sure I don't want to allow
Bishop takes Bishop so I don't think I
have any other candidate move to
consider let's take here first so now I
take I think in the end my queen ends up
on this square and I'm up upon take
stakes I take here first and then I take
here I don't know I feel like I'm just
winning upon here but who cares what I
what I feel let's see what I know here
let me just work this out for sure
believe I'm just winning up on e takes C
takes these guys are now off the board I
exchanged a pair of rooks and then I'm
on this twice there could be a check on
c1 king h2 isn't an issue I mean my
queen will be in the center you can't
argue with the Queen in the center let's
do it we're going to take with the pawn
for starters we'll be with the rook or
the pond yeah I guess we're just going
to enter a position where and I don't
see anything great that they could
let's exchange rooks first a big moment
here should probably take with the Queen
and I mean I could take one of these too
but I definitely want to take out the
this guy here he is past after all Queen
takes rook takes rook takes Queen takes
he's have to be on the lookout and be
tough one to convert even though I'm
soon to be up a pawn it'll be a tough
one to convert get that full point so
many okay that is a bit surprising I
thought yeah I thought going into a
queen clean only endgame is best
so just Queen takes pawn I'm improving
my queen by doing that rook c2 king h2
if there's ever a queen check I could be
blocking on d6 at that point let's do it
I'll mop upon I have a very central
clean and there's still rook on board if
I could exchange Queens and obtain an
active rook let's say on the a file
where I exert pressure on the pond and
have this kind of structure okay
probably just king h2
yeah King h2 and you know what I think
I'll be playing f4 if I'm checked yeah I
can't block with the rook I'll be
dropping my beep on you know probably f4
another thing is by having upon on f4
for example Queen c7 knife I block Queen
takes rook takes rook c2 is tending
towards a draw with this truck hitting
everything so if I can meet a queen
check with f4 at least I won't have to
worry about the rook hitting at my
second drink with the strike against my
F pawn of course I am putting myself
into a pin
I'll have to be putting myself into a
pin no matter what on a check against my
king so I think the best approach is
with f4 they try to strike away at the
pinned pawn queen here f4 g5 they're
probably asking for trouble I could get
the Queen's up with check an immediate
check and a check on a recapture and
then my rook gets really active if I
could get this pawn without one of these
two pawns following some will certain
win to 34:25 moves in very simplified
position okay
probably have four let's do it I
maintain my queen position I feel like I
need to get the Queen's off in order to
try to win this
and I'm maybe a step away from doing
that
I would really like to have my pawn on
b3 what would I do on Brooke c2 what I
get won't go for that Queen exchange
okay there is a check here let's
consider these checks clean check first
okay hang on that I mean they're really
asking for some trouble let's start with
b3 just getting out of the line of fire
rook c2 is a good way to lose just to a
basic fork so I don't know if he's any
it's one of those situations where I
don't know if the King is any safer on
h7 than he is on g8 and why I feel like
you safer here you know I got I got some
checks so I probably have to do this
okay but now am I not able to slather on
in there clean f6
we have six threatening rook here and
then here is this going to be a problem
mmm-hmm well what I could do now I can't
go here I drop out for this is an
interesting move
clean up six Queen c5 you know what I'm
just going to play the move hmm rook f1
is interesting for white as well or for
black putting pressure on f4 how about
how about Queen d6 yeah let's go Queen
d6 and I'm doing this to get this kind
of rook transfer as mentioned if I could
establish this rook on a a6 where I
defend my pawn and I exert pressure here
I also have some sixth rank pressure
also be easier for me to play taking
into consideration my clock the Queen
goes too far f7 is unprotected
you know let's see let's see what black
does
I'm two moves away from that quick rook
transfer don't know that I want to do it
right now okay
the queen is staying very active maybe
looking for this stuff
well I'm going to put pressure on this
pawn for starters threatening matin - no
not really
clean it after block so King here I'm
going to be giving a check get the
Queen's off and this is all I want not
asking for much more
if the king goes somewhere here I could
I'll be the one who gets at the king
first there isn't a good check for black
so I'm prepared to double on their
eighth rank if they get too fancy so
let's see if I could convert this rook
endgames well I didn't even consider
that huh
well they are attacking my f4 pawn they
may revisit c3 I may have to go to d4
yes essential oh brother
who how did I allow that
um that's not too cool let's go here
my king is going to be running I'm doing
this to offer a queen exchange and watch
out for an ensuing Queen e1 hmm can I
dodge checks I can't be able to run all
the way up here I have these squares
covered the diagonal I just have these
two covered my major pieces will cover
that if my King ends up getting flushed
up here that's tense yeah it's very it's
certainly very tense for me for as long
as the Queen's are on board so Queen B 1
I could go straight in for rook d7 or or
up to d8 I think both would be good I
like rook d7 better yeah I have all
these squares covered if my king is on
g3 this square covered my pieces are
controlling a lot of squares from
ensuing checks when my king is on g3
let's see what black does Queen takes
pawn too
when this rook hits here he's
threatening to take advantage of the
pimp on with a six
you
let's see less than six for my opponent
first time playing this guy
what other moves are therefore black
besides a rook h1 and Queen B one Queen
B one rook d7 they'll probably get mated
so rook h1 it's either a queen exchange
wreck h1 King g3 what's the follow-up
I'm playing a I'm playing rook to d7
very soon I have mating ideas of my own
this rook isn't really coordinated so
well with the Queen striking at h3 but
the squares where the Queen and rook
intersect I don't really see them
supposed Rock h1 King g3 and Queen g1
now mmm I would definitely make
think hopefully don't they don't do that
you can't work that one out
I should probably get on that crook h1
King g3 Queen g1 there's Queen h2 could
I just
okay once oh they're going for that okay
so I could exchange Queens but no let me
go straight in for this I could walk I
could walk you know I was tempted to
take the Queen for sure
my king is just slipping out rook h1
king g3 I don't see a good follow up
Chuck h4 I just take yeah this Queen I
mean I have a very central Queen an open
position like this she's doing great
great things currently I'm threatening
matin to here and then here one way or
the other screen g5 can't allow rook
takes pawn so they have to take my queen
I just recapture I'll be winning one
more pawn at least I could insert a
check first King g3 and then exchange
Queen's rook h1 King g3 h4 King takes
pawn g5
to do something like rook takes h3 I
could just take with the King Queen h1
King g3 I got everything covered all
these squares are nirmai control so how
are they ever getting checked to my king
when he's over here less than 10 for me
under 3 for my opponent and I think it's
just lost 4 block only move for me well
there's no good follow up check h4 King
takes pawn what more I have my own
threats here not only mate but even to
exchange Queens and pick up upon two
connected passed pawns two pawns up you
know I don't believe there is anything
the more they think the more okay more
confident I'm getting here got to save
that a pawn but I think he's just going
down take with check first why not
and then we scooped up the a pawn who
cares about the e pawn at this point
yeah I think it's silly to try to hang
on to this guy let's just coop scoop him
up and
let's get the King gone I was
thinking about just hiding my king III
could have done that
I still have an active rook oh brother
nearly lost on time applying this poor
brother
oh good grief I have to read win this
now oh brother that was so awful what I
just did there I should have just put my
king on h2 and then just walked with
these guys how I managed to lose a pawn
over here okay well now I'm still up the
two pawns I'm okay with giving up one of
these two pawns I'll be there in time to
get behind this guy
very very
a very bad technique okay let's just
track that pond down
you've gone check happy I'll lose my a
pond
now skewers I just want to get here and
just start pushing this guy create some
space between these two the king ever
moves I keep pushing and I finally have
the coordination I would want the I'm
not happy with myself you could hear to
my voice I think there was a an
opportunity for black to maybe even draw
I'm seeing things I thought the rook
maybe went here to attack my rook
so I'm going to push my beep on as far
as you can go and then help out with my
rook a little bit to push the pawn
through all right let's defend stay out
of the pawns why they're under 20
all right let's go here just duck for a
moment push and I'll be going to one of
these two next I don't care about my
Jeep on at this stage right here King to
the C file and then push through
maybe they resign here nope maybe we're
playing on to checkmate less than 10
it's not a game I feel good about must
be said and not cool okay good game good
game let me I want to I feel like I just
want to go to the end game real quick
before anything just to quickly show
let's get the euros off real quick just
to quickly show another approach I could
have taken so silly to even drop upon
like that at this point here I don't eat
my king so I could just get on with
pushing and pushing and just go here and
just to verify I mean these these two
pawns and rook are they could push
through on their own so it was
unnecessary for my King to even feel
like I shouldn't have felt the need to
try and activate my king it's
unnecessary when I have these two
connected past pawns
was it a draw around here yeah it's well
now it's not a draw but maybe there was
some kind of drawing resource for black
but should never got to that point just
hide my King on h2 just just start
pushing my pawns right here okay well in
the end still got the W but not a good
feeling you know when you don't convert
that ending well at all all right let's
have a look at it I feel like it could
probably go straight into the analysis
very quiet a game a lot of
simplification you could see let's see
these are the master games so this
position has been seen before these are
some higher level games or this exact
exact position has popped up as we could
see very draw ish hmm yeah very
simplified position I think I just have
a I don't know it's my preference to
play with the white pieces here and have
something to strike out like just
blundered upon if you played a little
bit too fast here with d4 you know I
just dropped upon I think that's what
the graph is going to confirm I mean
it's just a and it's small advantage for
me and then soon as they play d4 I have
a I got a pond and I guess even you know
even when I messed up with the final
position with the technique I still have
still the preferred side but yeah maybe
even some drawing possibilities for
black really just uh it just gifted me
up
on there let's have a look at it
there isn't any sharp position where I'm
wondering at where this was there a
tactic missed I don't think that's the
kind of game we played here very quiet
Queens gambit declined tartakower right
that says modern variation yeah we put
the arrows on
mmm-hmm what is it suggesting for black
instead of d-4d forgives me upon that's
what they played so rooks c7
um I guess I want to look at this
because I was I was mentioning I wasn't
so fearful of let's say you know queen
bee for this may drop upon as well but
you know just to highlight there is no
possibility really ever for D for my
bishops the more secure of the two I'm
putting pressure I have an aggressive
Bishop there in a defensive post and
yeah I could take up a spot on d4 and I
guess I could go straight in for winning
upon as well huh
not quite rook d4 a5 and now it wants to
take mmm feels like it's still tending
towards a draw if I go in for this you
know something like this these guys will
be exchanged most likely and then it's a
four versus three don't know if I'm
really in favor of that right around
this point if something like that
happened I'd be more inclined to take
over control of the C file and then do
something like this get my king up on
the d4 square I don't want to enter rook
ending like that where it's warmer that
where the extra pawn I have is just on
the Kings side you know four versus
three that's not it's not cool with me
at all I mean it's going to be very very
difficult to win that you know I don't
see myself winning that but my point
here is that I I will I wasn't fearful
of this Queen B for move if they're
having to recapture with the C pawn but
if they have a five in and I don't know
let me just kind of make up a nothing
move and now they're playing this this
is a different story
Queen takes pawn takes and now I'm
having to work against three three pawns
here you notice the evaluation here it's
already preferring
blacks um it's b3 you know this is this
is something that could be putting
pressure on
notice also with these pawns further
advanced their King is able to find it
easier to play a constructive role in
the endgame much sooner than me
you know if the King gets up here and
let's say one rook is exchanged I think
he could be quite comfortable on d6
what's still a couple of rooks onboard
maybe would be I would feel at least a
little bit uneasy if the black if the
black King tries to take up a post on d6
with two rooks on board but yeah main
point here I'm not fearing Queen B for I
know this is that this is I an idea but
I'm not fearing it until there's upon on
a4 a5 supporting the be four square I'm
not sure what more to really cover and
this one very quiet I'm up upon don't
believe anything was minced check it
does like f4 85 now King there just
popped up for a second King g3 okay b3
yeah I believe I was able to voice
everything I wanted to during the game
about how I'm just looking for a quick
rook transfer you could just put that on
the board to show like right here
instead of Queen c3 suppose they go in
for an exchange I mean as it played out
I took their F pawn and then they're a
upon and I'm up to clear pawns and I
converted it poorly as you saw but
suppose they go straight in for a queen
exchange at this point and then play
rook c2 I'm plying rook a six and he's
just a super piece you know he satisfies
the defensive role active and defensive
piece so there's this and then I could
kind of well I could slowly advance some
b4 b5 a
or my king could come over to assist
this rook is excellent I really can't
say enough about a rook on this square
ties down the rook to defense defends my
base point and cuts off the king he
doesn't have an easy time you know maybe
going towards the center not that he
would want to go towards the center but
he kind of has to walk a tightrope like
this and meanwhile maybe I could be
making some headway in this direction a
really strong post have a black I would
have black in a restricted position and
I could I think it popped up g4 at one
point I'd be a little hesitant to do
that just yet you know they might start
giving a bunch of checks to my king like
it happened in the game when my king
tried to get active but could get my
king in position say King here and just
creep over a little bit and it even
suggests this and we're seeing the
influence that the rook has on the sixth
rank if he ever pushes I'm winning the H
pawn and if he ever comes over here I'm
really quick to just get back over there
and it's the same story if there's a
take double isolated pawns and now I
have I passed pawn to work with it's
just a super piece and be really really
tough I believe for black to hold this
if they went in for a Queen exchange
because of this idea to transfer my rook
to the a file and b3 hat playing b3 has
that very idea in mind because if I'm
playing this right now Queen takes rook
takes
now there's rook here and it's a much
different story here rook takes rook
takes and this is tending towards the
draw as soon as I play here the rook
gets behind and this is this will be a
drawn endgame I won't be able to make
progress here with the rook being stuck
it'd be different if they're the roles
were reversed
if I had the rook if my rook was on a 2
in there Rick was on a 7 in a defensive
position then I could keep pushing but
ah and not the story in this in this
endgame
anything else missed don't think so
h5 rook d7 yeah it's just lost here so
instead of h5 I guess they had to try
rook e1 and then exchange Queens huh
rook takes I still kind of I certainly
like my position here
I'm still trying for something but what
more to add oh it's that if the rook
ever moves from this square then I have
that one moment to make that transfer
and it's suggesting that I could just
improve my King I have my base points
covered ok f4 might fall at some stage
but I think I could kind of do something
like this you know just head over
towards the Queen side my rope defends
both base points he cuts off the king
from maybe trying to help out towards
the Queen side yeah this would this
would be the approach I believe I would
be taking that approach just improving
my king position they played a rook to
e1 exchange Queens and then improve the
King they played h5 and then it's gone
yeah there isn't anything against my
king
I have everything covered as I mentioned
during the game h4 I just take g5 I
could just take with the king or even
the pawn oh excuse me anything but the
pawn anything about the pawn there
please you don't want to drop your queen
how awful would that have been King
takes is fine f6
f 6 is illegal that should probably wrap
this one up okay yeah
these weren't amounting to anything
short story these H pawn moves my king
was secure enough and I was there in
time put pressure on black
okay quiet game gifted me upon and I
converted it mmm but not so well in that
end game again I could have just tucked
my king away I didn't need my king just
put him on h2 and it may come at a
snail's pace but I could just kind of do
it like this you know if there's our
rook exchange it's one King and pawn
ending so this would be the approach
takes forever but I have I have forever
to get these funds rolling okay well as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
and I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye